breaking news to bring you this  afternoon we are receiving reports uh  hotly anticipated before that the  chancellor quasi-quarting has been  sacked let's bring in immediately our  Deputy political editor Sam has he gone  two sources say that quasiquating has  been sacked as Chancellor this isn't an  official announcement they're not doing  that yet we will get that I suspect  fairly soon but two sources now saying  that quasiquating has lost his job huge  uncertainty about what happens next  because Liz truss appears to have just  sacked the man who was at her side all  the way through the leadership contest  has been at her siding cabinet for years  and who has been on the same ideological  Journey as her for years for a decade  and that means she is now trying to save  her Premiership by drawing a line under  the last turbulent six weeks of her  Premiership and start afresh